bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce 7 8 l'actu
de ce mardi 4 mars nous allons passer en
revue l'information du jour et puis de
d'abord cette donc cette mobilisation
des élèves infirmiers partout en France
ce mardi pour dénoncer les difficultés
d'obtention de stage à La Verrière au
sein de l'Institut français en soins
infirmiers pas moins de 150 étudiants
ont participé à la manifestation
parisienne nous les avons rencontrés au
sein de leur établissement des
témoignages recueillis par Yolaine
Torres et Patrick Jacques de Dixmude
elle a verrière ses élèves de l'institut
de formation en soins infirmiers se
prépare il s'apprête à rejoindre les
centaines d'autres étudiants infirmiers
à Paris pour manifester leur indignation
la fédération de l'hospitalisation
privée a appelé à ne plus accueillir
d'étudiants en stage après le 1er mars
on a deux stages en fait par année si on
fait passer deux stages on valide pas
notre année donc du coup on se révolte
contre ça parce que ça joue ça met en
jeu notre diplôme et ça met en jeu aussi
la qualité de la prise en charge des
patients et c'est toute une organisation
autour qui fait que
cette décision de ne plus prendre de
stagiaires est une réaction à la
publication du ministère de la santé il
y a quelques jours elle annonce une
baisse des tarifs des cliniques tandis
que ceux des hôpitaux restent stables le
gouvernement entend ainsi compenser le
crédit d'impôt compétitivité dont les
cliniques bénéficient contrairement aux
hôpitaux en attendant les étudiants qui
se disent prisent en otage dans ce bras
de fer espère pouvoir être replacé
ailleurs dans cette école de la verrière
les 240 élèves des trois promotions sont
concernées on devait démarrer le 17 mars
en deuxième année et du coup comme il y
a pas assez de place de stage pour tout
le monde ça a été décalé au 31 mars pour
pouvoir trouver des solutions se laisser
un peu plus un peu plus de temps pour
trouver des solutions en fait
la ministre de la Santé Marie seule
Touraine s'est voulu rassurant hier elle
affirmait que tous les étudiants
concernaient trouveront un stage au sein
des hôpitaux publics des établissements
privés abusent non lucratifs ou des
centres de lutte contre le cancer une
mobilisation cette fois nationale serait
prévue dans les prochains jours
allez on va rester dans le domaine de la
santé la ministre de la Santé Marisol
Touraine a annoncé ce mardi la création
d'un statut médical des sages-femmes au
sein de l'hôpital public ainsi qu'une
meilleure reconnaissance de leur rôle et
de leur compétences et d'ailleurs l'une
des cinq mesures du plan présenté par la
ministre des sages-femmes je vous
rappelle qu'ils sont en grève depuis le
mois d'octobre dernier comme vous pouvez
le voir sur ces images au centre
hospitalier Mignault au Chesnay et des
sages-femmes qui malgré les annonces de
la ministre ce steam toujours
malentendus ce soir en ce qui concerne
notamment leur souhait de statut de
praticien hospitalier leur
revalorisation salariale et nous
reviendrons demain dans le 7 8 lecture
un peu plus longuement sur ce mouvement
un mouvement qui pourrait se poursuivre
elle est toujours dans le domaine de la
santé la société
ivinoise installée à Vélizy karmat avait
implanté le 18 décembre dernier le
premier coeur artificiel dans la
poitrine d'un patient de 76 ans et bien
ce patient est décédé dimanche 75 jours
après avoir reçu cette prothèse une
prothèse qui reste malgré
comprends plus célèbre dans le
département que Landru était yvelinois
et qu'il a vécu à Gambais était un peu
surnommé le barbe bleu d'ailleurs de
Gambais il a été accusé d'avoir tué 11
personnes
et il a d'ailleurs été guillotiné à
Versailles devant la prison de
Versailles le 25 février 1900 22 vous
avez choisi de revoir ce procès de
réviser ce procès alors pourquoi
dans cette affaire si le doute ne plane
pas on peut quand même considérer que
peut s'agir d'une certaine somme de
vengeance en somme dans dans le fait
jamais avoué il n'a jamais avoué et on
n'a jamais retrouvé les prétendues
victimes il a fréquenté énormément de
femmes parmi toutes ces femmes 11 ont
disparu 10 + d'entre elles pardon mais
malgré ça jamais on a retrouvé de trace
et il s'est toujours défendu en restant
toujours très poli très cartésien donc
celle-là quand même
la vérité il a toujours gardé pour lui
et au moment de sa mort il a dit que
c'était son petit bagage
alors ça peut ça peut tout rien dire et
tout dire
alors quel est le rôle de l'association
justement donc vous revoyez
régulièrement l'association revoir
régulièrement des grands procès il y a
eu la faire un outil l'affaire Dominici
tous les ans l'association revisite un
procès donc qu'elle décide de
retransmettre de rejouer complètement au
tribunal de Grande inst de Versailles
c'est l'occasion d'impliquer du
personnel étudiant mais aussi le
personnel de l'université afin qu'il
travaille ensemble ça apporte une
ouverture d'esprit ça permet de à chacun
de trouver des responsabilités qui
s'agisse des gens qui se responsables du
projet des étudiants qui s'impliquent
tout simplement dans le projet parce
qu'ils vont comme on le voit sur les
images il parle devant un procès
précédent je crois que c'était l'affaire
Dominici ou un outil enfin
effectivement le moindre étudiant qui
passe même en tant que témoin a déjà un
rôle à appréhender c'est jamais évident
et doit développer un peu son aisance à
parler devant il y a quand même 250
places dans ce tribunal ça leur permet
de débloquer des éloquence et s'ils
décident au métier de juriste ça peut
leur être très utile notamment même pour
le public c'est vraiment enrichissant il
y a beaucoup d'étudiants qui viennent
assister au procès ça leur permet de
découvrir concrètement la procédure
pénale et de la vivre en direct et pour
eux ça permet de concrétiser les cours
qu'on a en fac à l'amphithéâtre c'est
pas souvent concret c'est du de
l'abstrait et là de le voir et de le
vivre d'entendre les sentences réclamer
par le procureur c'est quand même
important et est-ce que ça veut dire que
vous reprenez les minutes précises du
procès ou est-ce que vous je sais pas il
y a une autre liberté non pas du tout le
but est justement c'est tout est fondé
sur une certaine liberté dans la mesure
où premièrement dans ce projet là après
avoir défini à faire en question le but
est vraiment de retranscrire le dossier
de l'affaire donc c'est pas forcément
évident notamment que l'affaire a
presque un siècle et une fois qu'on a ce
dossier là justement souvent la coutume
si vous voulez veut que ce soit des
charrettes TD qui investissent le rôle
d'avocat on leur remet le dossier et à
partir de celui-ci ceci cela va en fait
en tirer leur propre conclusion avec les
conclusions on sait pas demain quelle
sera l'aboutissement
alors qu'il avait pas avoué que
effectivement les corps ont pas été
retrouvés et ça veut dire que demain
soir au tribunal de Versailles aura
peut-être une autre sentence d'autres
arguments c'est ce qui permet de
distinguer la chose une pièce de théâtre
dans le sens où on ne sait pas
l'aboutissement je pense que ça c'est
intéressant et que cette affaire Landru
je ne sais pas si le ministère public
justement demandera la tête de l'andru
encore une fois mais si c'est le cas
c'est quand même une tension pourrait se
faire ressentir ça sera palpable si vous
voulez puisque c'est quand même dans
cette salle même qu'il y a 97 ans je
crois c'est mémoire est bonne que
justement Landru a été condamné à
mortrier enfin présumé vraiment
meurtrier puisqu'il était il a dit oui
il était jugé c'est un meurtrier
Illinois et qu'en plus il a été jugé
dans cette salle de Versailles donc
c'est d'autant plus d'autant plus
symbolique vous êtes trois au sein de
l'association vous êtes deux
représentants vous êtes trois en fait
avoir du projet au centre de ces
associations puisque nous sommes une
vingtaine dans le streaming que ça
demande beaucoup de temps de préparation
Lorenzo depuis le début de l'année enfin
l'année scolaire on est sur ce projet là
c'est à dire il y a plusieurs étapes il
y a d'abord reconstitué le dossier
ensuite il faut aussi rechercher les
témoins les le président de la cour le
les différents assesseurs et ceux qui
vont participer en tant que personnel du
tribunal et leur donner les rôles et
être sûr qu'il s'approprient bien leur
personnage et la faire en elle-même
parce que les contexte aussi historique
est complètement différent on est quand
même dans la période de
au tribunal il y aura aussi des habits
d'époque ça sera les années 20
que les témoins ont à charge cela c'est
à eux de faire en sorte d'interpréter au
mieux leurs personnages ensuite chacun
peut se permettre une petite fantaisie à
la limite mais le but est quand même de
rester fidèle à l'époque dans le sens où
c'est une reconstitution de procès donc
nous devons être quand même fidèles
il y aura la barbe mais pour la calvitie
on est un peu jeune en fac donc c'est un
peu malheureusement ça va être compliqué
à ce niveau là mais c'est peut-être la
voilà mais sinon non quel rôle vous
allez jouer vous allez forcément jouer
un rôle aussi alors Lorenzo sera un rôle
du père de grand-père le maire de
Gambais donc
deux amis des victimes ont contacté le
maire de Gambais pour leur faire part de
leur inquiétude et c'est à partir du
maire que l'enquête finalement c'est
enclenché jusqu'à la découverte
finalement des différents noms sous
lesquels Landru se faisait appeler
pseudonyme en face
Guyet ça a mené à Monsieur
Dupont donc il y avait énormément de
monde
et vous Antoine c'est-à-dire que je
serai à côté du président de la cour en
fin de l'aider comme j'ai principalement
beaucoup travaillé en fait sur le sur
l'écriture et la rédaction du dossier le
but de l'ascesseur est de pouvoir
informer en temps réel en fait le
président de la cour de l'orienter dans
les discussions et de l'informer de
répondre à toutes ces questions sur le
dossier mais aussi de lui dire voilà on
a quand même un planning à respecter
bien sûr il est totalement
comment dire totalement on peut s'en
détacher en fait mais le but est quand
même de pouvoir orienter les discussions
convenablement de façon à me mener bien
le projet donc et bien cibler les
questions qui sont posées au témoin et à
l'accusé
pas vraiment en fait on travaille avec
eux sans eux le projet n'existerait pas
puisque c'est nous qui leur demandons de
l'aide dans le sens où ceci les avocats
sans eux on n'aurait pas de conclusion
tout simplement il y aurait pas de
jugement pareil pour le président de la
cour ensuite c'est vrai qu'on a été en
total autonomie tous les trois donc avec
Pauline qui n'est pas là ce soir étant
total autonomie pardon pour Rigel
dossier ça c'est vrai que ça a été assez
dur il y a eu des nuits blanches etc on
s'en est remis Antoine vous vous êtes en
deuxième année de droit
en première année qu'est-ce que ça vous
apporte ce travail concret parce que là
c'est un vrai travail concret en fait ça
apporte une ouverture d'esprit à la fois
je pense que ça apporte vraiment une
ouverture d'esprit moi c'est vrai que
j'aime bien le travail de recherche
pourquoi une ouverture d'esprit une
ouverture d'esprit dans le sens où on se
détache en fait de sa de son statut
d'étudiant pour pouvoir aller ailleurs
en fait et ne pas regarder que par cela
c'est à dire que bien sûr je reste
étudiant je peux pas être là si je fais
pas convenablement mon travail
d'un autre côté on a quand même des
obligations derrière presque
professionnelle qui viennent alors que
j'ai pas encore toutes les
responsabilités qu'on a un certain âge
ça me permet de d'avoir voilà comme je
disais des responsabilités c'est à dire
peut-être qu'à 20h j'ai fini ma journée
de cours mais maintenant il va falloir
faire ça si on veut que derrière on
puisse aboutir sur un projet c'est
pareil pour Lorenzo on a tous pris des
initiatives à un moment donné
c'est un projet qui touche vraiment à
plusieurs domaines à la fois c'est que
c'est vraiment ce qui m'a plu dans la
constitution de procès à la fois il y a
un vraiment un domaine juridique qui est
important parce que ça se passe
directement dans un tribunal il y a
toute une part de la communication de
recrutement finalement et de
d'organisation au sein de l'équipe avec
les témoins les différents avocats c'est
comme ça touche un petit peu à
différents domaines ça devient vraiment
enrichissant pour l'étudiant qui apprend
à être autonome et à gérer un projet de
A à Z par lui-même quand vous sentez le
réveil du gros procès disons que on a
été ce qu'on est stressé depuis le début
de l'année presque on a ça il y a ça a
été dur mais là techniquement en fait
tout est en ordre on est content de
pouvoir je pense qu'on va pouvoir passer
une bonne nuit la veille du la veille de
cette reconstitution
tout passionné peut venir d'ailleurs
récurrent tous les ans il y a des que ça
soit des journalistes des gens qui
veulent écrire un article ou même toute
personne qui va en passionner de la
faire la porte est ouverte demain
mercredi à partir
de
c'est demain mercredi à partir de 13h au
Versailles autre tribunal de grande
instance de Versailles voilà merci
beaucoup à vous deux d'être venez en
plateau nous parler de cette initiative
allez on va quitter l'univers judiciaire
pour un tout autre monde alors là c'est
vraiment sans transition on va aller du
côté de la ferme pédagogique de la base
de loisirs de Saint-Quentin en Yvelines
pour découvrir le parcours du lait ou
comment on fabrique du fromage vous
voyez bien que ça n'a rien à voir un
sujet signé romain grabette et Patrick
Jacques de Dixmude
comment manipuler les crayons de chèvre
la ferme pédagogique de la base de
loisirs de 50 ans en Yvelines propose
tous les dimanches matin un atelier
d'initiation destiné aux enfants toutes
les étapes de transformation du lait en
fromage sont au programme à commencer
par la traite des chèvres le but c'est
vraiment d'apprendre en s'amusant et en
posant des petites questions par exemple
pour le lait de savoir qu'une chèvre
elle a besoin d'avoir un bébé pour pour
faire du lait on demande à quoi ça sert
le lait pour enfin pour nourrir qui pour
nourrir le bébé et il trouve
intuitivement les enfants apprennent
ensuite les rudiments de la fabrication
du fromage le lait filtré afin d'enlever
toutes les impuretés quelques gouttes de
présure d'origine animale sont rajoutées
pour coaguler le lait et après une
journée d'attente il faut dégoûter le
lait caillé dans des faiscelles le
fromage doit ensuite être salé et placé
sur une grille munie d'un store
dégoutage il ne manque plus que la
finage et le séchage j'ai trouvé ça très
intéressant et on s'est bien amusé on
rigole et je m'étais jamais intéressé à
ça et maintenant et ben j'aime bien
savoir mais pas question de dégustation
à l'issue de l'atelier pour des normes
d'hygiène le fromage doit reposer avant
d'être goûté
ces éditions est maintenant terminée
merci de votre attention rendez-vous
demain direct à 18h dans quelques
instants c'est le magazine municipal
présenté par wilfriedrichy il sera
notamment question d'un site de campagne
piraté cela se passe du côté de l'école
bonne soirée